Senator if you would uh let us just be a
wait a minute more we're waiting for a
ranking member to to join us hopefully
good morning everyone one
I hope everyone had a wonderful weekend
we will now open up the public hearing
on Senate Bill 32
and the chair recognizes the prime
sponsor Senator Rosenwald thanks for
coming
for the record I'm Cindy Rosenwald I
Hampshire over that period will receive
more than 300 million dollars to
mitigate the harms of the opioid
epidemic
when we receive a check from one of the
companies that we're in litigation with
15 percent of that money goes out
immediately to 23 litigating
subdivisions as counties and its cities
and towns the balance goes into the fund
none of the money goes to the state the
opioid and payment advisory commission
has a responsibility and authority to
Grant these monies for a variety of
purposes that are laid out in statute
there are 22 members on the commission
and they represent subject matter
experts HHS Corrections the Department
of Justice County attorneys the
governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs Physicians Specialists and
County and Municipal governments
we held our first round of Grant
applications last fall for 6.7 6.6
million dollars and at the beginning of
this month 14 contracts were awarded by
the executive Council for six 6.5
million dollars there's one outstanding
contract that's not quite finished
since that first round more money has
come into the fund and we're just about
to close an RGA for at least five
million dollars in Grants to reimburse
the cost of medications
to treat substance use disorder
to reimburse those question can I
interrupt it so what's an RGA I'm sorry
a request for Grant application
um the so this bill comes out of our
experience in soliciting and awarding
grants over the past year does several
things first it establishes a
requirement that we give out grants of
at least five million dollars at least
once a year
so as long as there is at least five
million dollars in the fund we have to
give out grants at least once a year and
we have to collaborate with HHS on the
number of times that we will do this in
a year if we go beyond two or three it's
going to be
really overwhelming for the Department
and I should note that it's very likely
there's going to be at least five
million dollars in this fund every year
for the next 18 years because of the way
the settlements are structured
but currently there's no statutory
language about this it's dealt with in
rules
second the bill clarifies and makes a
couple of additions to eligibility
categories for Grants
these are recommendations from the
subject matter experts it expands the
reimbursement for medications for a
substance use disorder treatment to
recognize that naloxone is not the only
FDA approved substance
and finally it updates language to
reflect best practices in the field and
fixes a couple of typos in the
underlying statute so I'd be happy to
answer questions
attorney buffetti who has negotiated all
these settlements at Justice is also
here and he's he's really the subject
matter expert but I'm happy to answer
questions
thank you very much Senator um so of
course we're the second committee on
this so we will not be discussing the
underlying policy and we thank you for
all your hard work on that
um so we're going to be focused more on
the money side of things could you just
explain where do the 5 million come from
what what was the decision I want why
not three million why not 6 million
um
we decided so we had about
35 million dollars
in the fund some of that is from
multi-year settlements but a big chunk
of it was from a one-time settlement
from Johnson and Johnson we didn't want
um we didn't want to start funding
programs that would ultimately not be
sustainable
so we thought five million dollars was
reasonable but we allowed the department
to increase that number we have not yet
seen what the total request
will be let me say that in the fall when
we went out to be on 6.6 million dollars
we got 24 million dollars in requests so
there's a huge need out there we think a
lot of the reimbursement requests will
be for County Corrections
for the cost of treating their
um in their inmates
with either naloxone or
um buprenorphine or
methadone but it won't only be counties
there may be some local
jurisdictions as well so we might be
able to decide to give out
up to 10 million
thank you so much it was really just
yes I saw that you were reading do do
you have a copy of that
um
and do I can leave this with you thank
you
the questions from the committee for the
senator representative self-worth yes
thank you for taking my question and
thank you for all your efforts
um very important topic for me I've
heard in many meetings of the need
especially smaller communities to get
reimbursement for the Narcan and those
other kind of treatments but I also know
grants are very complicated so I'm
hoping eventually there'll be an easy
way for them to access that if they
aren't a community that necessarily to a
really big Grant
so so that is part of our learning
experience our first round of Grant
applications we had a very long
application
and we have determined that we're going
to work to have
shorter
applications and also by targeting
some of the rounds like the one we're
doing right now is reimbursement only
the one we did last fall was for any of
the approved uses it will be easier I
believe for smaller communities to apply
for reimbursement or or any other Grant
that we go out with I think we'll be
going out with grants again later this
year and probably discussing it
next in two weeks as our next meeting
oh thank you I do think that that
flexibility will really be helpful
especially if that's the main thing a
community needs is Narcan reimbursement
because of course it can be very
expensive that if they know that's
something they can apply for I just
think it would ease some of the stress
thank you some of those communities may
have applied during this round that's
just about to close but we don't
no yet
what has been applied for
both representative uh I need to be
close I need to bring it closer on that
reminded me of something that I've been
meaning to ask about dhhs's Grant making
process
there was a number of years ago our
senior center was having to send three
digital and I think it was 30 paper
copies of each application that they
made to DHHS
we seem to have had to promote paper
pushers when we when after the Great
Recession
do you know if that's been fixed I'm not
aware that we were acquired anybody to
submit multiple paper copies could you
just ask
thank you
representative run
thank you madam chair and thank you
senator for taking my question
um are there any administrative costs
that are taken out of this fund and if
so what's the percentage yes that's a
great question we agreed to fund one
um
staff person
was between 85 000 and a hundred
thousand a year all in with Benefits the
department has been asking for several
more staff people we have been reluctant
to approve
that request it's a big request we might
we might decide to fund one more but we
haven't come to agreement because we
really want the money
to go to mitigate the harms not to
hire
staff the governor's Commission on
Alcohol and Other Drugs which spends
between I think 11 and 12 million
dollars a year has one staff person so
representative Malloy
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for uh taking my question today
I'm interested in the Grant application
process
uh is when when one organization applies
or money is the grant uh
a
standard form with specific questions
and that everybody gets or is the Grant
application uh
something that these organizations
make their own case for uh and it's free
form uh process in other words I don't
know if I'm asking the question quite
right but I
is it is it this question and this
question and this question in this
question I think I understand her
question we had a standard application
um and we knocked out a couple of
applicants because they were not in good
standing with the
um
with was it the Secretary of State
charitable trust unit so a couple of
organizations applied and we just said
you know you're forget it we're not even
going to consider any non-profit that's
not in good standing with charitable
trust we're not going to give this money
to get your house in order but we've had
a standard application
thank you very much we're going to try
and make shorter thank you
representative spilsber thank you madam
chair
Senator I just want to make sure uh that
I understand the legislative intent from
your perspective as the sponsor
so the five million dollars
is addressed in two sentences in the
first paragraph So This is
the first page of the bill lines six
through ten
what I understood you to say is that you
are wanting the legislative instruction
that at least 5 million be granted each
year
what this language appears to say is
that
grants will be made without specifying
how much
in any year that the balance exceeds 5
million
that leaves me with two questions
the first question is where does it say
that
at least 5 million should be granted
each year
and should it say that is that your yeah
I think I misspoke it it says you're
right
as long as there is at least five
million in the fund every year we would
go out to
solicit applications at least once
um it doesn't say that we have to give
out five million there might be a year
where we only have five million and we
decide to bid out four
so I think we were comfortable with this
so you're comfortable with what it says
yes and it didn't necessarily have to be
a minimum it does it does not okay cjhs
was concerned that we would decide oh
let's go out to bid every quarter
and that would be too much work if
you're happy with it I'm happy we're
happy with it second second question
then it looks to me uh given the pace of
settlements that uh we won't be below 5
million uh in any given year anytime
soon but at some point down the road as
this moves into the 10 to 18 year range
uh what does this language indicate in
terms of a year in which maybe there was
only three or four million in the fund
does it mean nothing can be granted in
such a year
that's what it seems to say I don't I
don't think so it just means we don't
have to
so the requirement is us as if there's
at least five million we have to give
out grants at least once a year okay so
you're you I get what you're saying
shall solicit applications is an
instruction if there are five million or
more you would not want it to be the
case that if there were only three
million in the funds no grants could be
made
right no I think because we might want
to spend what you have yeah right okay
and we could change it in 15 years from
now
thank you I'm glad to have your
representative Malloy did you have
another question yes thank you uh Madam
chair thank you again Senator uh earlier
in the in your testimony you mentioned a
number of 35 million dollars and I don't
know if I heard this correctly or that I
thought I heard that you have 35 million
in this
fund now is that that's correct attorney
Buffet has the exact numbers but it's
somewhere around that because we got a
one-time settlement from Johnson and
Johnson that's not going to be paid out
over 18 years so some of the money
that's in the fund is the first payment
out of
10 or 15 or 20. and some of it is lump
sum I think we're about to get a
one-time payment from Walmart
also but
if we give out all of that money right
away then
we are not going to be funding
sustainable programs so we've tried to
be
um
realistic we haven't given out
necessarily one-year grants we've said
give us an application for something you
would do over two years or three years
so we want to work with the requesters
to mitigate the harms but in a way that
is sustainable we have not yet
had the opportunity as a commission to
say how much do we want to set aside
for the future and give out
more slowly
follow up so that's why you're
protecting that Corpus of 35 million at
this point just for now okay yep thank
you
other questions from the committee
representative Southworth uh thanks
again for taking my question you
partially answered it again I was a
counselor by trade so I know this is a
gigantic problem uh very complicated uh
and even 10 years we're probably talking
20 but um as far as dealing with it if
not almost forever it seems like what
you're looking for in this is you really
need flexibility on the financial side
because you really you know as a
commission don't really know what you're
getting into I mean in some some of
what's going to work you know how much
each uh
attempt to work on the problem costs I
mean it seems like you really need
flexibility as a commission and probably
might even come back to us at some point
um we do we want both flexibility but we
also want a statutory requirement so
that there's transparency of we're going
to be giving out money at least once a
year when we have a decent amount so
that
the public knows
uh what we're doing with it and that
that statutory Authority has not been
there
then
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you so much thank you
I'm gonna have to run off okay across
the street but um I'm going to give
representative but my thank you we
appreciate that
Mr buffetti from the doj is here would
you want to come up and maybe answer
some of the questions we heard earlier
if you don't mind happy to welcome thank
you very much uh for the record my name
is James buffetti I am the deputy
Attorney General
for since 2015 I have been the state's
lead prosecutor Prosecuting uh our
claims against opioid companies
um and um
I think that's it's probably best to
think of these as separate settlements
each one was separate some of them came
out of bankruptcy courts some of them
have yet to be resolved in bankruptcy
courts most infamously Purdue farmer
which is uh which is tied up in
bankruptcy litigation in the second
circuit uh I can tell you that
to date we have received
slightly over 45 million dollars in
opioid money
as the senator says the statute
requires that 15 percent
off the top of whatever money we receive
goes to 23 subdivisions
all 10 counties and 13 cities and towns
why do they get the money they get the
money because they hired outside Council
from out of state to file their own
opioid cases in federal court
and because of that the legislature
determined that they should and only
they should share in this uh in the 15
percent and it's done by population
so today to date we've received uh I'm
sorry we have sent out
6.842 million dollars to the 23
subdivisions and that money's already
out that money is already in their hands
and they are doing various things with
that many of the counties are using the
money to help with their cost of
medication assisted treatment uh which
is the probably the most effective
treatment for people who are suffering
from an opioid use disorder
currently in the uh in the opioid uh
trust fund it's a dedicated trust fund
there was 31.7 million dollars if you
deduct that 6.5 million that was just
recently granted
to those uh those those
organizations that were able to get
grants approved by the governor and
executive Council so that's 31 million
dollars as the senator
said we will receive these payments in
different amounts in different times
over the next uh 17 years I think it's
fairly it's it's it's a fairly sure
thing that we'll receive at least five
million probably much more than that for
that entire time
the the largest settlement was with the
three major drug Distributors uh
McKesson Cardinal Health and Amerisource
Bergen
that um that was a hundred and
uh
112 million dollars over 18 years so
it's going to come in at about five and
a half million dollars a year I think
there is some some variation depending
on the terms of the settlement
um we also have just uh just at the end
stages of settling with
um CVS Walgreens Walmart and two uh of
the major manufacturers company called
Teva and a company called Allegan
those settlements are various amounts
over various uh various periods of time
uh but that's a hundred million dollars
just for those five settlements as this
as the senator said if the Walmart
settlement is finalized and we should
expect to receive about fifteen and a
half million dollars sometime this year
alone
so I'm happy to answer that's a lot I'm
sorry there's a lot of of of information
but I'm happy to answer any questions
about where this money comes from uh
these settlements
um and what we can anticipate the
senator is correct I think that the
estimate is in total when this is all
said and done the state will receive
slightly over 300 million dollars over
and thank you very much are are you
comfortable with the 5 million and the
way this is worded is that situation I
could also say I'm also a member of the
opioid abatement commission so we've
worked closely with that group it's a
it's a diverse group and um I'm
comfortable with it uh it's a commission
that's working well uh I I think that
the the questions about you know the
timing and the amount and I think it
it's it's meant for some flexibility
um we should anticipate at least one
round of Grant applications a year I
think it's probably more like two or
three that we can do we part of that
limitation is the amount of work it
takes for HHS and their contracts unit
to actually do this work and to make
sure that everything is done properly
and to make sure that the money is being
used for the purpose for which it was
intended and that takes a lot of
resources but I think once once we get
into the groove I think that we should
anticipate at least two or three Grant
applications a year so that the object
is obviously to get this money out as
quickly as we can and to use it for
opioid abatement purposes and no other
purposes uh it was from from the
beginning of this case there was there
was strong intent by the by the AGS
across the country that this money be
dedicated for opioid abatement purposes
and not be diverted into other other
things so I think the goal is to get the
money out as quickly as we can so that
it can get into our communities and to
help people struggling with opioid use
disorder
thank you are you open to questions of
course uh yes representative Bolton
thank you madam chair
um this may not be in your bailiwick but
regarding the one staff person that DHHS
will receive
what would the function of that be and
it seems like if they're handling all
the grant applications that are coming
in perhaps reviewing them and bringing
to the commit the commission
um is that it or so so I I have to
correct Senator she was
she has been dedicated to the Senate
finance committee work the last couple
of meetings she missed the last meeting
in the last meeting the commission
agreed to a second position
um and um the the chair so the chair of
the governor's Commission on alcohol was
there he's on the commission as well he
has pledged to try and find funding for
at least one more position through the
governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs
so as I understand it's it's it's
easiest to think of these as what
happens up front as these Grant
applications are being received and
reviewed uh and then what happens at the
at the other end when that money is
going out and there has to be some sort
of an audit function so these two people
will be on either end probably working
together on all of it but we'll make
sure that these that each Grant
application has to be carefully screened
uh and then presented to the commission
and then when that money goes out then
there needs to be somebody that is
checking on it to see that it's being
properly used and that the organization
that's using it has the ability to do
what they say that they're going to do
and it's I mean this is at the end this
is you know this is New Hampshire's
money and we want to make sure that it's
being used wisely properly and it's
going to the to the best effect
thank you
representative homie
thank you on
the alcohol and drug other drugs I don't
think that's its actual name but it is
actually it's the community on Alcohol
and Other Drugs
over time I was there when it started
um they they are working on the wider
part not just other drugs but also an
alcohol but on more on prevention and
and on education and one of the problems
with concentrating just on nalaxon and
it's and the others is that
um people take it and then go straight
back to using again and take it again
and again and their brains go fuzzy from
what I understand on
are are you collaborating with is is the
commission collaborating with that
commission uh in terms of joint strategy
or are you going to
that's an excellent question and um
it it's actually in the bill that
Senator uh put together that um there is
a requirement now that the commission
Works in coordination with the
governor's commission uh and it's on in
the first section uh line 13. so um and
there are many of us that are on both
commissions so
um there has been a concerted effort to
get as much coordination as we can on
this issue about how to best use the
money to the best effect so we we're
we're obligated and we had been anyway
to talk to the governance commission to
talk to the the the the the governance
coordinator on drugs uh Chief Mara to
talk to uh as many as we can to make
sure that we
um that we can figure out what are the
best strategies to use this money and
the the statute that created the opioid
abatement Commission
has about 14 approved uses including
prevention treatment transportation to
treatment transitional housing coming
out of treatment so my guess is that
they will also be um some some
applications for prevention work in the
schools last year the legislature
amended the statute to to specifically
allow for prevention uh work being done
in in our schools
um and so I anticipate as things go on
that there will be applications to the
commission for those kinds of projects
yeah so you may also be working in
creating safe houses for people that are
coming out of treatment that badly need
not to be in drug infested yes so so I
can tell you that for instance in this
last round
Sullivan County is in the in is is in
the process of rehabbing a building
close to their jail for transitional
housing and
um so and Sullivan County is one of
those counties that receives the chair
of the 15 but in addition
we authorized a grant of about a half a
million dollars to help them with this
project
um
you know the experts that that do this
uh tell us that housing transitional
housing is a is a key need so I think we
want to make sure that we address that
um and provide options for people that
need it the other one of the other key
needs uh in the North country was
transportation to and from treatment and
so one of the grants that we that we uh
authorized was for a non-profit to
purchase two Vans solely for the purpose
of transporting people to and from
treatment
so we want to make sure that if if
somebody needs it they have available
treatment that they can get to in a
reasonable amount of time you know New
Hampshire at one point we were we had
the second highest overdose deaths in
the country
just after West Virginia which is not
something to be proud of and so and that
was many years ago we've done an awful
lot of work to address that issue and
that number has come significantly down
um
we we um we we opened up these doorways
programs in mostly in hospitals so that
people can get to a treatment provider
quickly and get connected with services
and we've done a lot but we need to make
sure that if if somebody needs it they
can get to treatment quickly and then
they don't overdose uh overdose deaths
are still on the rise uh and this a lot
of work to be done uh to to address that
but I think we've made progress and we
need to just figure out how we can
continue doing that what is the greatest
need and that's going to change over
time as this crisis changes and so the
commission needs to be flexible again
needs to talk to the governance
commission needs to figure out what is
what what are the best strategies for
now to to address the crisis as we see
it and then try and fund programs that
that do that
representative Southworth
thank you for taking my question
um and thank you for the context you've
been giving us I so want to follow up a
little more uh about the cost of the
medicines like Narcan because I know
might have been a year ago I was in a
meeting and you might have even been
there where a number of people were
saying can't you just pay for the Narcan
or whatever I assume probably you
haven't made a decision yet about to
what extent you're going to pay for
those things but I wondered if you have
a sense yet of what actually would be
the annual cost to support New Hampshire
communities and that one part of the
program I don't that's a good question
representative thank you I don't know I
think we're going to find out when we
see this this this next round of Grant
applications coming in so this this
Grant application was specifically
designed for the reimbursement of
naloxone and for for suboxone so it was
and it's geared toward you know cities
and towns counties who are who are
having to use this I mean one of the
reasons that uh reasons that I overdose
death rate has come down is the amount
of naloxone but nalox let's be clear
naloxone is not a treatment drug
naloxone is a rescue drug it prevents
people from dying on the spot because
opioids have an effect of suppressing a
person's respiratory system so it if you
have a seat there's a very actually
YouTube videos and you can see an actual
patient being given naloxone and they
come back to life
um and so but they're but they're
critical right and then the hope is that
you can now get them into treatment so
that they don't overdose again but
that's a cost and so a lot of a lot of
First Responders have it but there's
also been a lot of work being done by
HHS to make naloxone available to people
who have an opioid script so you know it
it should be that if you're if you're
properly on an opioid prescription that
you be given the option to also get
naloxone to carry in your in your pocket
like an EpiPen so that if something
happens you have something to to use uh
and and so I think I think we'll find
out how many how many people apply for
that and how much that is
but it's gonna be it's gonna be
um millions of dollars I think follow-up
yup I've at least for me um it would be
great
um if we could um have figures on what
if
um these grants covered all of the
rescue drugs it may be if that could be
a category because I just think that's
where I'm hearing a lot of things about
people really wanting to use them but
also wanting to know that there's a
reimbursement especially in smaller
communities
I I think that would be important data
to have uh as because you know there was
a there was tracking that he's been
that's being done by the department of
safety of of the amount of naloxone that
is given out uh so we we it's it's not
perfect data but we have some data and
indicating that it's actually you know
been significant and it has had an
important effect on on helping um uh get
that overdose death uh rate down
this is more comment than a question
question but I just wanted to thank you
for your extraordinary work producing
over 300 million dollars with of course
many others at your side I recognize
that but it is extraordinary and uh
perhaps a drop in the bucket when we
consider the magnitude of the issue that
you're trying to address intelligently
and with the help of all the others that
are on the commission so many thanks
thank you
I just wonder if you can give me a
clarification on what was being said
about Staffing because is that in some
other part of the RSA because the part
that we're looking at doesn't say
anything about paying for administrative
costs it it doesn't that's a good
question it's not in the the bill it was
anticipated that there would be some
administrative costs
um simply because you just can't you
can't award this money and do it
properly without some administrative
costs so the commission had voted to uh
to recommend that we have that HHS hire
two people one's already been hired and
so are how are you how are those people
going to be paid are they supposed to be
paid out of this fund or it does it it
doesn't
is it in some other part of the statute
because this part here doesn't have any
provision for paying a state stat
staffer it it is not in this in the
statute there's no mention of it in the
statute as it currently exists there's
no mention for the the payment of
representative ulery and then
representative Susan almi
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um probably one of the few people in
who's actually administered naloxone
um and it does work rapidly however I've
also administered it to the same person
more than four times sadly yeah does the
department do does anyone anywhere have
any record as to how many times that's
because
how many times have been multiple
applications of that emergency drug to
the same person
my experience in the field was
no one takes
the the treatment which has some of the
same parameters as alcoholism having to
reach bottom Etc uh as seriously because
they're not facing death because I'll
get a shot and I'll be saved
uh as an excuse right in their in their
own mind so are there any records on
that no and and
um so safety has they have some records
as I said it was not perfect data of the
amount of doses of naloxone that has
reported to them that's been
administered but they don't have data
and I'm not sure they could do it they
don't have data on how many doses have
been given to uh to the same person
and get
yeah yeah because oftentimes depending
upon transport time because it's it's a
short-acting uh drug that's a short
period of time and there may be multiple
doses within the hospital while they
detox the person I understand that
um
but there should be in my opinion some
record keeping I would hope you would
take that back
um when these the follow-up question
manager
yes as long as it's pertaining to the
money aspects of this bill which is our
Focus thank you
when the money that you've gotten from
these companies that were fulfilling a
um well so we mean when that money stops
coming in right
um
that's going to be 17 years from now
um when all that money stops so I don't
know where we are I we have no idea what
the status of this opioid crisis will be
in 17 years
um I think those are very good questions
um you know there has been a lot of
federal money that has come in
for opioid use disorder work so much of
the money that goes into the doorways
has come from federal opioid grants and
there is a question about what happens
when that money stops and there's
indication that it's going to be at
least reduced so I think those are hard
questions that will need to be addressed
uh it's I I anticipate that they are
going to come to the commission and say
can you help make up some of this
shortfall uh because I think I don't
know offhand but I think just to to keep
these doorways programs open it's
probably 50 or 60 million dollars a year
a lot of it is coming from I guess a
Federal grant that won't go on forever
and I think we're going to have to
figure it out but again we don't it's
hard to anticipate where this where this
crisis is going to go and what our needs
are going to be 5 10 20 years from now
okay
okay representative almond did you have
your hand up yes you did we were waiting
for you
yeah well I uh just trying to clarify on
representative
I'm forgetting names again pillows
uh uh question on is the the position
that is already hired now in the budget
the new budget
because these things don't appear in
statute they appear in the budget right
I don't know the answer to that I I know
that the position I know the position
was created by HHS I know that the
funding for it would come out of this
opioid uh I I don't I don't know the
answer to that and presumably what's
paid for was uh
agreed to by governor and council at
some point yes thank you
thank you for your patience other
questions on this side of the room
anything else
thank you very much
okay I don't have any other pink cards
anyone else here would like to speak on
Senate Bill 32 seeing none we will close
okay folks
um we will now break for caucuses and
come back around 11 to uh exact four
bills that are due representative all me
thank you
I may have missed this I'm I'm uh sorry
there's quite a lot of uh construction
going on on 89 now and I've got some
other problems but uh I've got Senate
Bill 113 in front of me we we also did
and we've inquired of Karen and she said
that was a mistake so ignore that
so what we have uh we have four bills
that we'll attempt to exec today and we
really need to get them done today
because we're up against deadlines so uh
hopefully we can do them efficiently but
we might need to give it a few hours if
there's other amendments that need to be
made so let's plan to meet back here at
11.
thank you oh and Welcome to our new
members for the day the substitutes
we'll introduce you when we come back
thanks
uh the Republicans have a room up on the
third
okay good morning again
welcome back
uh we will open up our executive session
on four different bills today and but
before we do we'd like to welcome our
substitutes today can we go around the
room representative smart
hi welcome where are you from
um District Two Belknap County Meredith
and um hi everybody hi glad to be here
thanks for coming having me
representative Lloyd hi Crystal Lloyd
you must like us because this is
becoming a habit yeah you guys tend to
be my favorite to sit in and sub with
that's awesome and then over here
representative run yes Rosemary rung
Hillsboro District 12 which is a town of
Merrimack
and representative Hawkins Phillips hi
yeah back from Hanover and lime and it's
always a pleasure to be back on always
means thanks for having me
thank you for being here today okay
first on the docket we will open up the
executive session on Senate Bill 32 and
the chair recognizes representative
spilsbury for motion
thank you madam chair I move OTP on SB
32. is there a second
representative elberger seconds
representative spilsbury would you like
to speak to your motion
thank you so our focus is principally on
the 5 million dollar
item and I was glad that I was able to
have a colloquy with Senator Rosenwald
and would like to make sure that
our committee report provides the
necessary legislative intent
to ensure that this is understood to say
the department must have at least one
rfg round
whenever the fund is over 5 million
but that does not preclude them
from providing grants when the fund is
under 5 million and it does not mean
that they have to spend at least 5
million
so with a consent and understanding of
the committee I want to make that
explicit in the committee report
other comments representative Mommy
thank you I think it should also put the
the maximum maximum idea in there that
on the fund is being created by a
mixture of long-term of of one time and
uh serial on
on contributions
on from the settlements and can be
used in larger amounts in some years
agreed and I'll make that clear too
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
thank you representative janigan yes
representative ulery yes representative
set
yes representative spilsbury yes
representative yes representative smart
yes representative Saudi yes
representative orrs yes representative
Rochford yes representative Almy yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative Lloyd yes representative
fellows
yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger
yes representative rung yes
representative hacken Phillips yes and
the chair
I'm not sure we can put this on consent
but if we can is everyone okay with that
going on consent yes okay so the vote
being 20-0 ought to pass motion carries
and that closes the executive session on
okay we will now open up the executive
I've I've been advised two different
ways on that so what I will do is I will
recognize you for ought to pass with
your Amendment and then you can induce
your Amendment and we'll see if it
passes or fails and then we'll go from
there sound good okay
okay so we'll Now open up the public
excuse me the executive session on
Senate Bill 49 and the chair recognizes
representative fellows uh for emotional
thank you ma'am cheer I'd like to move
for Senate Bill 49 Amendment
2023-2031h
the bill is now open for another
amendment chair recognizes
representative ulery
uh Madam chair
um I move ought to pass on Senate Bill
49 FN
representative Orr seconds
representative Ellery would you like to
we've heard enough on this uh this bill
between the one that I offered in this
one
um the purpose is to provide some uh
bridging uh because of the existing law
which lapses all of the funds into the
uh the general fund each uh biennium in
addition
um
uh the way that this bill is written it
includes a provision to produce
licensing fee costs to individuals
requesting permission to do a business
in the state of New Hampshire so
thank you
other comments from committee members
representative Phyllis
so thank you madam chair um I can't
support
this as written because of my concern
about
for actually I have two concerns one of
them it's not drafted correctly
the um there are parts that are new
language that are not highlighted that
would leave somebody to believe that
they um
that uh the oplc already has the
authority to
lapse money
um for capital projects
and that's not in current statute
also
it conflicts with
HP
655 which is the a Big Bill it's like oh
I don't know like eight pages or so that
reorganizes oplc and that has passed the
house and the Senate and it's on the way
to the governor's office and this
um says that the fund shall be separate
and dedicated non-lapsing continuing
continually appropriated to the office
for the purpose of paying all costs and
salaries associated with the office
it does not say anything about
restricting it specifically to Capital
expenditures
and
um
the third thing is that we heard that
the commissioner the commissioner um the
executive director of oplc was
interested in purchasing a building and
existing statute makes it very specific
that is the responsibility of admin
Services their division of purpose of
purchasing properties
to make purchases of buildings and also
to execute long-term leases of which
oplc currently has
leased facilities with seven more years
left on that lease
um
and so the process would normally be for
any agency that wanted to have a new
facility or a new lease they would go
through purchase and property to
identify what you know if it was needed
what facilities might currently be
available to them and then it would go
through the budget process and the
entire budget process it would be put in
the budget going to the governor and
work its way through the house and the
Senate so this language which I think in
terms of restricting it to
capital
appears to give them the authority to
make Capital purchases which
current statute just does not allow so
they're just some issues with this I do
absolutely that's why I had an amendment
which dealt with the 3 million you know
put the 3 million cap in there but
um
which I think everybody's on board with
but maybe not and just address those
technical issues thank you
thank you representative and just so you
know uh representative fellows did some
research on what administrative services
does and has some handouts for you if
you're interested
okay any other discussion on Senate Bill
seeing none the clerical oh I apologize
representative Almy
yes
um
there is that section that the Senate
put into law and the drafting did not
uh
did not indicate that that section was
actually new
so that everybody's been under a false
impression of what the law was
originally that I find on
very irritating frankly and and think
that we probably
ought to do something about that
um
and
the
I'm I'm just looking at this now and
realizing
that I don't
see
in the bill that we're talking about
the cap of three million dollars
or any cap
any apps Jay
it does seem like my version is wrong
here because I know I've read that
elsewhere
no that's a report oh yeah here it is
yeah all right okay I don't know where
this version came from
it's from a senate amended by the Senate
but
okay other content comments
um
I do wonder if there's anything that we
to indicate that the law is being
changed here
on those section that section that
representative fellows has pointed out
without changing the rest
Jennifer hi
a quick question for our researcher uh
there are some language that wasn't
highlighted
when we received it from OLS
is there a way to get that done now uh
or
and apparently this language was not
highlighted inside the Senate either
the drafter just didn't do it I did
contact the um the drafter and she
indicated that there was an error when
they were working on this bill
um that error is not present in the
house bill version
um but it is present in this version
she did suggest an amendment to correct
that
could we do that
on the floor
yeah yeah and just just so you know
representative fellows and I spoke last
week about this and I thought there was
going to be a separate bill that did
that didn't happen so we could do if
it's a technical fix like that the one
that got rid of the capital yeah okay so
we could do if that's something simple
it's not just like a major policy change
right it's just a
correcting of what's bold is that yes
she she characterized it as like a
copying and pasting error like the
formatting didn't enter into the program
as she expected it would when she went
back and reviewed it again
um when I asked the question so it's not
anything substantive it's just
an unexpected word processing
error representative Oliver a question
do scrivener's errors require such as
this require an amendment or can that be
just be considered a scrivener's error
and be corrected by a uh
two-person uh I could follow up to ask
specifically whether this is something
they could correct and enroll to bills
when I asked her about the problem she
suggested an amendment
rather than suggesting that enrolled
bills would be able to take care of it
so it's I'm not 100 certain but I could
follow up on that would you please I'm
sorry to put you on the spot thank you
for being here
awesome okay so we'll ask her to do that
research and let the committee know and
if we feel if if it turns out that we
need to do a floor Amendment
we can certainly do that
okay any other hands up to make comments
on senable 49
okay seeing none the clerk will call the
room and the motion before us is ought
what would we do if she says we need an
amendment then one of us will have to do
a floor Amendment but no later it has to
be done until the clerk no later than 4
pm the prior day to session
there's no session this week so it'd be
for next week so we have a little bit of
okay the clerk will call the rule thank
you madam chair
representation
yes represent ullery
um yes representative Doucet yes
representative Pillsbury yes
representative yes represents smart yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes reprint yes represent Army
representative Ames yes everyone's
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Lloyd yes representative fellows no
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative wrong yes
representative hacken Phillips yes
and the chair
yes okay that's nineteen to one
about being 1901 ought to pass motion
passes uh I believe it could go on the
consent calendar I'm not sure if
that's right we don't want it on a
consent calendar so we'll put it on the
exactly right so we'll put it on the
regular calendar
and we will close the executive session
okay we will now open up the executive
session
on Senate Bill 112 and the chair
recognizes representative ulery for a
motion
I moved to retain
is there a second
by representative elberger
representative
ullery would you like to speak to your
motion uh there are questions and there
are questions
therefore
I question whether or not we should pass
it
other comments from the committee
representative
thank you
um
I think that most of the people on the
committee would like to use this
opportunity to to figure out what
problem gaming uh
treatment is doing in this state and if
there's any way we can make it work
better on and we
we also have a bit of a mess with how
representative Platinum we have a
version to online gaming this is online
gaming
this is a different bill this is
um more the breakage issue remember we
went through all the math equations and
so forth okay other comments on Senate
bill 112. so
representative fellow so just to
identify some more of the questions
um one of the things we know is that for
paramutual racing that not all the race
tracks are using the same breakage
and the other concern is like I I don't
know about anybody else but I had no
idea how they're dealing with breakage
on the historical horse racing machines
which is so we definitely need to
understand what what's going on with
that breakage how that works
just to emphasize uh representative
Almond's note about problem gambling ice
or gaming you know I see these words
used interchangeably I sometimes wonder
about them gaming and gambling
um but um
I see this as one more opportunity
there's also a study commission to
look closely at to surface the issue of
problem gambling and to see what we're
doing about it already and what we ought
to be doing about it and how it's
affected by
the expansion of legal
gaming into what we now recognize our
casinos in New Hampshire so I look
forward to
working with this bill as a retained
Bill and anything else that's there that
can be part of this
to
see if we ought to be doing a better job
on addressing the the downside of
thank you represent only did you have
another comment oh sorry I should
mention that I am involved in the
charitable gaming industry I didn't
think about that with this bill because
I don't think it directly impacts me but
any other comments
seeing none of the clear so the motion
is to retain see none the clerk will
call the role
thank you madam chair representative
janigian yes this is to retain
representative ulery yes representative
Doucet yes representative Pillsbury yes
representative plant votes yes
represents smart yes representative
Saudi yes representative orrs yes
representative Rochford yes
representative Army representative Ames
yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Lloyd yes representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes represent
elberger yes representative wrong yes
representative Hagen Phillips yes is it
hack and Phyllis or haken hacken like a
computer hack okay thank you hack and
Phillips uh and uh the chair yes the
voters 20-0
vote being 20-0 the retained motion
carries
okay we will now open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 190 in the chair
recognizes representative Doucet
promotion
hey Madam chair I move we retain SB 190
FN is there a second
representative Orr's seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
very briefly uh as with the previous
Bill we just retained there's many
questions that remain unanswered here
any expansion of gaming in the state
needs its due hearing and do diligence
and I think we have the time and the
availability to take care of that and we
shouldn't rush into judgment on this
other comments from the committee
representative Phyllis
um yes I I agree with the idea to retain
it some of my concerns are
how is this even any different than
sports betting
and why isn't it under you know under
that
um
we know that
Seabrook
already has the what do you call it
Advanced Deposit they it's at the brook
they actually are holding money on
deposit for the races and their rate is
1.2 percent not the what's proposed in
here and I think that my biggest concern
is that when you have to if you move
this to essentially be you know online
that
you we probably are getting less Revenue
than we would get if it's done in person
because people that are in the casinos
not only are they they betting money but
they're also buying liquor and they're
buying food and and the state is getting
revenue for that so this is really a
tiny slice of money that we would be
getting and it just said the whole
concept
doesn't work for me
thank you other comments from the
committee representative orrs did you
want to say anything just checking oh
I'm sorry on this side any comments okay
I'll say it again I'm part of the
charitable gaming industry I don't think
this impacts me but just for the record
uh what are the odds of it affected
um the motion before us is on retain the
clerk will call the roll
okay the motion is to retain uh
representative janigian yes
representative ulery yes representative
yes representative yes representative
yes representative smart yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes representative yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative Lloyd yes representative
fellows yes representative Bolton yes
representative uh elberger yes or
observed wrong yes and representative
hacken Phillips yes and the chair yes
vote is 20-0 to retain the vote being
20-0 the motion carries and we will
retain this in committee and close the
executive session on Senate bill 190.
I believe when you're done
so great job everyone uh very efficient
uh I think that's all we have left to do
on our committee at the moment
um unless we must produce Revenue
updates or something like that I'll keep
you posted if that comes up
the speaker has said that there will be
no meetings in July or August
so we gotta plan on June though there's
a lot going on in June so be here
um but
um we will meet in September and we'll
probably
start with just like a work session to
talk about all of the retained bills
I've lost count now but it's over a
dozen
so we'll go through that list and see
where we are and then maybe schedule
further work sessions with experts to
educate us further
and we also talked about September maybe
doing a little welcome back